patients are my top priority and I will
be their Champion focusing on the issues
that most affect them or their loved
ones
most of the time patients have a great
experience
but we not must not paper over the
problems that we face
we expect backlogs to rise before they
fall as more patients come forward for
diagnosis and treatment after the
pandemic and the data shows sadly that
there is too much variation in the
access and Care people receive across
the country
the scale of the challenge
necessitates a national endeavor
as we work together to tackle these
immense challenges I will be proactive
not prescriptive in our approach as we
apply a Relentless focus on measures
that affect most people's experience of
the NHS and social care
today we are taking the first step in
this important German journey by
publishing our plan for patients which I
will lay in the libraries of both houses
it sets out a range of measures to help
the NHS in Social care perform at their
best for patients the plan will Empower
and inform patients to live healthier
lives place an intensive focus on
Primary Care the gateway to the NHS Ms
people use prevention to strengthen
resilience in the health of the nation
and improve performance and productivity
to succeed we will need a true National
Endeavor so supported by making it
easier for
professionals to return to help the NHS
as well as drawing on the energy
enthusiasm of the million people who
volunteer to help during the pandemic by
opening opportunities for them to help
in different ways that could be by
becoming a community first responder or
by for example strengthening Good
Neighbor schemes across the country and
we will also be exploring the creation
of an ambulance auxiliary service
I'm Jesse speaker the plan sets out our
work on the ABCD of priorities that
affect most people's experience of the
NHS and social care
first ambulances
I want to reduce waiting time to
patients and apply a laser light focus
on Handover delays so ambulances get
back on the road and to patients where
they are needed most
our analysis shows that 45 of the delays
are occurring in just 15 Hospital trusts
that is why the local NHS will be doing
intensive work with those trusts to
create more capacity in hospitals the
equivalent of 7 000 more beds by this
winter through a combination of freeing
up beds with a focus on discharge and
people also staying at home and being
monitored remotely through the sort of
technology that played such an important
role during the pandemic in addition
when patients call 999 speed of
answering is critical so we will be
increasing the normal number of call
handlers for both 999 and 111 calls
next modern Deputy speaker the backlog
where the waiting list for plan care
currently stands at about 7 million
exacerbated by the pandemic this summer
we announced that we are virtually
eliminated weights of over two years and
we we remain on track to reach the next
milestones in our plan
to boost capacity we are accelerating
our plans to roll out Community
diagnostic Centers as well as new
hospitals and we will maximize the use
of the independent sector to provide
even more treatment for patients
as well as capacity we are also getting
more people on the front line making it
easier for people to work in and help
the NHS
we know that people are leaving the
workforce for a variety of reasons
we have listened and we are responding
addressing a number of these reasons for
instance currently pension rules can be
a disincentive for clinicians who want
to stay in the profession or to return
from retirement and help our national
endeavor
but we will correct those pensionals
relating to inflation we will expect and
trust trust to offer pension Recycling
and we will extend until 2024 measures
that will allow people to stay or return
to the NHS today Mr Speaker Madam Deputy
speaker I can announce that we will be
extending the operation of the emergency
registers for health professionals for
two more years this is of course on top
of commitments to boost the Health and
Care Workforce like our Manifesto pledge
to recruit fifty thousand more nurses by
2024 and that will sit alongside the
design and delivery of our forthcoming
Workforce plan
C is for social Care at the moment one
of the key challenges is discharging
patients from hospital into more
appropriate care settings to free up
beds and help improve ambulance response
times
to tackle this I can announce today we
are launching a 500 million pound adult
social care discharge fund for this
winter
the local NHS will be working with
councils with targeted plans on specific
care packages to support people being
either in their own home or in the wider
community
this 500 million pounds acts as the down
payment in the rebalancing of funding
across Health and Social care as we
develop our longer term plans
I know also there is a shortage of
carers across the country we will
continue to work with DWP on a national
recruitment campaign and in addition
since last winter we have opened up
International recruitment routes for
carers
we will support the sector with 15
million pounds this year to help employ
more care workers from abroad we're also
accelerating the roll out of
Technologies like digitized social care
records which can save care workers
about 20 minutes per shift freeing up
time for carers to care
finally modern Deputy speaker D for
doctors and dentists
I'm determined to address one of the
most frustrating problems faced by many
patients getting an appointment to see
their doctor or getting to see a dentist
at all
starting with doctors there are five
steps that we are taking to help make
that happen first setting the
expectation that everyone who needs a GP
appointment can get one within two weeks
second opening up time for more than a
million extra appointments so patients
with urgent needs can be seen on the
same day
third making it easier to book an
appointment for publishing performance
by practice to help inform patients
fifth requiring the local NHS to hold
practices to account providing support
to those practices with the most acute
access challenges and to improve
performance
clinicians are best placed to prioritize
according to clinical need of their
patients in July 44 of appointments were
same day appointments but too few
practices were consistently offering
appointments within a fortnight
now to help free up appointments we will
ease pressures on GP practices by
expanding the role of community
pharmacies and I'm pleased to announce
that today we have agreed a deal for an
expanded offer over the next 18 months
pharmacists will be able to prescribe
certain medications rather than
requiring AGP prescription as well as
other measures involving Community
pharmacists we estimate that this will
free up 2 million appointments we're
also changing funding rules to give
freedoms to GPS to boost the number of
staff to support their practice we
estimate that this measure could free up
a million GP appointments
for patients we will make it easier for
them to contact their practice both on
the phone while we are making an extra
31 000 phone lines available this winter
followed by further deployment of
cloud-based telephony and online
particularly via the NHS app
and as I set out the house earlier we
will also correct pension rules so our
most experienced GPS can stay in
practice
and by extending the emergency register
we are creating opportunities for people
other than GPS to undertake tasks like
vaccinations
now on dentists there are too many
Dental deserts
that is why we are setting out an
ambition that everyone seeking NHS
Dental Care can receive it when they
need it we've already started changing
the dental contract to incentivize
dentists to do more NHS work and take on
more difficult cases and I would like to
pay tribute to my predecessors in this
role for their success in beginning to
tackle this long-standing issue
we will also be streamlining routes into
NHS Dentistry for those trained overseas
so they can start treating patients more
quickly and we will make it a
contractual requirement for dentists to
publish online whether they are taking
on new NHS patients Madam Desi speaker
these measures across a number of
important areas are the start not the
end of our Ambitions for Health and Care
they will help us to manage the pressure
that Health and Care will face this
winter and next and improve these vital
services for the long term
my priorities are patients priorities
and I will endeavor through a powerful
partnership with the NHS and local
authorities to level up care and match
the expectations that the public rightly
have
whether you live in a city or a town in
the countryside or on the coast this
government will be on your side
when unique care the most Madam Deputy
speaker I commend this statement to the
house